en este vídeo quiero hablar acerca de
algo que se llama el determinante
hakobyan o 10 más o menos lo que suena
es el determinante de una matriz pero no
de cualquier matriz va a ser el
determinante de la matriz segoviana de
la que les he estado hablando en los
vídeos anteriores pero antes de que
pasemos a ese tema sólo quiero dar un
pequeño repaso de cómo plantear el
determinante en sí solo en un contexto
ordinario de álgebra lineal así que si
estoy planteando el determinante de
alguna matriz digamos que tenemos el
determinante de una cierta matriz y no
sé me voy a tomar la matriz una sencilla
la matriz que tiene en su primera
columna 30 y en la segunda columna 1
ok entonces me voy a tomar el
determinante de esta matriz y como nos
tomábamos el determinante de una matriz
bueno esto era igual y lo que hacíamos
era lo siguiente me tomaba la
multiplicación de la diagonal que va
hacia abajo es decir la multiplicación
de 3 por 2
entonces me quedaban 3 por 2 ya esto le
teníamos que quitar ya esto le tenemos
que quitar la multiplicación de la otra
diagonal que en este caso es 1 por 0
entonces me quedaría menos 1 por 0 y
bueno en este caso es simple 3 por 2
menos uno por cero
es lo mismo que 6 así que mi resultado
sería 6 pero sin duda hay mucho más que
un solo cálculo que está pasando aquí lo
que quiero que veamos es que hay una
intuición geométrica verdaderamente
agradable por ejemplo si pensamos en
esta matriz que tengo aquí como una
transformación lineal como algo que va a
tomar a este primer vector base 30 sobre
las coordenadas 30 y
este segundo vector va a ser sobre las
coordenadas 1 2
ustedes saben si estamos pensando en
columnas entonces pueden pensar en el
determinante como una medición de que
tanto esta transformación estiran o
aplasta el espacio y en particular
notarán que tengo esta región amarilla
resaltada observa esta región que tiene
una unidad cuadrada es decir tenemos un
cuadrado con longitudes laterales de 1
usuarias de 1 podemos compararla ahora
con lo que sucede después de la
transformación si me pregunto qué tanto
se estira o se encoge esta área la
respuesta es que se va a estirar por un
factor justo de 6 del determinante es
decir todas las áreas que podríamos
dibujar cualquier tipo de forma no
solamente esta área cuadrada cualquier
área que nosotros pensemos se va a
estirar por un factor de 6 y realmente
podemos comprobar esto viendo este
paralelogramo observamos el cuadrado se
convirtió en este paralelogramo que
tiene una base de 3 y luego tiene una
altura de 2 entonces 3 por 12 6
esto tiene que ver con el hecho de que
estamos multiplicando aquí 3 por 2
así que ahora vamos a pensar en que
podría significar esto pero en esta
ocasión en el contexto de lo que estado
describiendo en los vídeos anteriores si
recuerdan tenemos una función multi
variable en que se podía escribir de la
siguiente manera era una función de dos
componentes en la cual en la primera
componente tenemos a efe uno de xy era
una función multi variable con dos
variables xy y mi segunda entrada era
también una función de estas dos mismas
variables le habíamos llamado f 2 f 2
también de x james y le habíamos dado un
cierto valor a estas funciones habíamos
dicho que esto era exactamente igual que
el vector que tiene como entradas y
bueno la primera función era lo mismo
que la función x
el seno de iu el seno de bien y la
segunda función era bien más el seno de
más el seno de x esto era lo que
representaban estas dos funciones y la
idea era que esta función no es del todo
lineal va a ser todo bastante curvo y
complicado en cambio si nos acercamos
alrededor de una región en particular
que recuerdan era representada por la
región que tenemos atrapada en el cuadro
amarillo este cuadro amarillo es un
acercamiento entonces al aplicarle la
transformación se ve como una
transformación inicial de hecho puedo
reproducir esto hacia adelante y podemos
ver que aunque todo está alojado dentro
de esta versión ampliada las cosas se
ven ligeramente como una función lineal
notarán que tengo este cuadro amarillo
resaltado al interior y este cuadro
amarillo corresponde a la unidad
cuadrada que estaba indicada en la
animación anterior y de nuevo es solo el
marcador como algo que podemos ver para
saber qué tanto se estira el área de
cualquier cosa en esta región así que en
este caso particular cuando reproducimos
la animación
realmente no cambian tanto se estiran un
poco pero no es tan drástico así que si
conocemos la matriz que describe la
transformación de este acercamiento el
determinante de esta matriz nos va a
decir por qué factor las áreas alrededor
de este punto tienden a este de assen y
en particular pueden pensar este pequeño
cuadrado amarillo y el factor por el
cual se estira entonces vamos a
recordarlo la matriz que describe la
transformación ampliada era el jacob ya
no déjame ponerlo aquí el jaco piano que
tenía como componente es bueno la
primera componente era la derivada
parcial de la primera función esto con
respecto a x recuerdas y en la segunda
componente tenemos la derivada parcial
de la segunda función también con
respecto a x ok esto en la primera
columna y luego en la segunda columna en
la primer componente tenemos la parcial
de la primera función con respecto a g
en la segunda componente tenemos la
parcial de la segunda función de f 2 con
respecto también ayer ok
esta era mi matriz hakobyan y ahora lo
que vamos a querer es calcular su
determinante ahora recuerdan si evalúan
cada una de estas derivadas parciales en
un punto en particular
independientemente del punto al cual nos
acerquemos en este caso era el menos 2,1
una vez que introducen esos datos a esta
matriz lo único que obtienes es una
matriz llena de números ahora lo que
resulta ser una cosa bastante útil cosa
que veremos más adelante en los
conceptos de cálculo multivariable es
sacar el determinante de esta matriz
para analizar qué tanto el espacio se
está estirando o aplastando en esta
región así que en el vídeo anterior
trabajamos esto para este ejemplo
particular y llegamos a que esta matriz
la podríamos escribir de la siguiente
manera la podríamos escribir como la
matriz que tienen en la primera
componente de la primera columna el
valor de 1 que es la derivada de esta
función con respecto a x
me quedaría simplemente 1 y de igual
manera la segunda componente de la
segunda columna me queda 1 la derivada
de esta función con respecto ayer es
simplemente 1 mientras que de este lado
íbamos a obtener el coche no de x porque
observan estamos tomándonos la derivada
de la segunda función con respecto a x
entonces simplemente tengo que derivar
esta función con respecto a x y me
quedaría el coseno de x y por otra parte
acá arriba también me va a quedar el
cose no pero ahora que ya el coche no
deje esto porque estamos derivando esta
función con respecto a gemma y yo lo que
quiero en este vídeo es encontrar el
determinante de esta matriz así que
vamos a escribirlo pero el determinante
de bueno de todo esto que tengo aquí y
el determinante de todo esto que tengo
aquí va a ser simplemente como acabamos
de recordar multiplicar lo que hay en la
diagonal
entonces me quedaría uno por uno lo cual
es simplemente 1
entonces aquí tengo uno ya esto hay que
quitarle la multiplicación de la otra
diagonal que es coser no de x por jose
no te llama jose no de x por coseno de y
ahora nosotros nos estamos fijando en un
punto en particular en el punto menos 21
entonces déjame escribirlo quiero
encontrar este determinante en el punto
donde x vale menos 2 y donde ya vale 1
entonces vamos a sustituir por x igual a
menos 2 y menos uno justo aquí en este
caso tengo uno menos el seno de menos
dos pero el coste no de menos dos lo
calcula antes de empezar este vídeo
tú puedes hacerlo con tu calculadora y
ver que en efecto me den el valor de
menos 0.42 ok
esto lo voy a multiplicar por el coseno
de 1 aquí me quedaría el coseno de 1
pero también ya lo calculado
anteriormente y toman el valor de 0.54
de hecho esto lo vimos en el vídeo
pasado recuerdas 0.54 y cuando
multiplico estos dos obtengo
aproximadamente el valor de menos 0.22 7
que cuando lo multiplicó por este menos
se convierte en más y cuando lo sumo con
un hombre me queda que todo esto de aquí
todo esto de aquí es simplemente 1.227
esto evaluado en este punto recuerda lo
que estamos haciendo es obteniendo el
determinante total evaluado en el punto
menos 21 y entonces obtenemos que es
aproximadamente a 1.227 así que esto les
está diciendo que las áreas alrededor de
ese punto tienden a estirarse por ese
factor y esa especie de rectas terminan
en lo que veremos veremos que las áreas
se estiran
tal vez un poco pero no tanto cierto
solo por un factor de 1.2
ahora vamos a compararlo con otro punto
se me ocurre tomarnos el punto donde x
es igual a 0 y es igual a 1 así que aquí
en lugar de menos 2 voy a poner que x
sea igual a 0 déjame ponerlo con este
color para que veas que lo cambiamos y
entonces que voy a obtener bueno ya no
voy a obtener este valor de aquí es
cierto lo que voy a obtener ahora es lo
siguiente me va a quedar 1 - el coseno
de 0 y bueno el coseno de 0 es 1
por el coseno de uno que habíamos dicho
que era 0.54 ok pero uno por 0.54 0.54 y
uno menos eso es simplemente 0.46 así
que todo esto se reduce a 0.46 ahora que
cambiamos de punto y porque estoy
cambiando de punto porque observa a
causa del determinante de este jacob ya
no estoy obteniendo un número menor que
un hombre alrededor del punto cero uno
esto nos está diciendo que deberíamos
esperar áreas que se aplasten justamente
deberían de plantarse por un factor de
0.46 y veamos esto parece correcto si
estamos viendo la versión ampliada
alrededor de ese punto y las áreas
deberían de tender a contraerse
alrededor de ese punto y de hecho lo
hacen vean que se aplastan parece que
por bastante y gracias a nuestro cálculo
podemos concluir que se redujeron
proporcional
justamente por un factor de 0.46 esto es
lo que significa el determinante así que
como dije esto es en realidad una noción
muy agradable en todo el cálculo
multivariable y es que vive en un
pequeño entorno local alrededor del
punto y si solamente quieren tener un
sentido general para esta función como
una transformación que tiende a estirar
esa región o aplastarlos juntos entonces
esa función es el determinante de la
matriz hakobyan a la cual nos dice que
tanto cambien las áreas alrededor de
este pequeño entorno y con esto los veo
en el siguiente vídeo